a year of government imposed lockdowns
vaccine mandates mass mandates left and
right and now a plan for the irs to look
into your bank account i'm not kidding
it's really no wonder americans are fed
up with government overall and a new
gallup poll says this 43 percent of
americans think the government should do
more to solve our problems but here's
the big number 54 say
54 said they shouldn't maybe joe biden's
heavy-handed approach has soured some
folks so let's start with you janet this
poll surprised me in a time in which
people like to blame and point fingers
they're saying i want government to do
less they have too much and they've got
their hands in too many situations are
you surprised by this well but they
voted for an administration who would be
for more government control i i mean
this is the person so you think it's in
the response to what we've seen for the
last night i think so i think they're
frustrated and i think the best
illustration is college football okay
you see the stadiums full of like 80 90
100 000 people who say that
um but i think that that is people
showing up saying like we're gonna make
our own decisions and we've decided this
situation is okay with our risk
tolerance level they're gonna show up i
think that's the kind of pushback where
you're saying people are tired of
somebody telling them what to do and by
the way i have to mention this because
we had this on the show last night
university of florida i'm a seminal
these are gators but hey they have good
information and they said they've been
tracking these trends they say the the
chief epidemiologist they're tracking
these big football games because they
have big football games in florida says
not seeing any coveted ramifications
these outdoor events really are not the
super spreader events that people
worried that they were going to be so i
think
some americans are deciding that they
know better for themselves i didn't
think we haven't felt this way the
government was the problem remember
ronald reagan ran on that katie the
government's the problem get out of the
way uh and now do you think is this poll
convince you that america changed their
minds what do you need to see more you
combine this with joe biden's
polling numbers on his job approval and
yes they're getting frustrated but it's
more about the philosophy that you have
behind government so when there's a big
crisis people tend to think that the
government should be able to handle it
but then they screw it up and they go
too far especially democrats and
implement all these things that people
say are you know we could have done a
year ago they're not applicable now and
when you go from 15 days to slow the
spread to
a year and a half later of take a
vaccine or lose your livelihood in your
job and the ability to feed your
children i think people probably think
you're going too far but it also goes to
the fact that just this week the press
secretary jen stockey said that joe
biden is taking advantage of this crisis
to try and implement his 3.5 trillion
dollar agenda because they still think
that people are in crisis mode and they
want the government to to handle things
and take care of them but they've proven
on a lot of these things that they've
screwed up they've missed the mark and
they're going way too far when it comes
to controlling people's lives a year and
a half after this and jesse what they're
allowing what they're also saying to us
too and further in this poll is that not
only do we want to be left alone but the
stuff that you do have your hands in
want you to back off 43
of americans say there's too much
government regulation in business and
industry 25 say there's too little 30
say right amount people want the people
from the delhi owner to the restaurant
to big business back off let me try to
be successful i like these numbers a lot
there was a great piece today in the
post it was by glenn reynolds the
irrational covid regime is driving many
americans to a healthy non-compliance
and they use a term called irish
democracy so irish democracy is when the
country leave without you go to a party
and leave without saying yeah that's an
irish goodbye
but when the government we don't like
but we're not going to riot we're not
going to overthrow the government we're
just not going to comply we're going to
foot drag you know maybe we'll do a
little sabotage throw a little monkey
wrench in there and you look around at
america and that's what are we wearing
our masks here are we are in marinum
down below the nose are we not wearing
them all right social distancing okay
i'm going to the beach i'm going to the
football game all right you know what
not feeling too good today i think i'm
about to call in sick sorry if your
flight's canceled that's where we are in
this country we didn't like what they
did with telling us how many people we
could have in our restaurants they made
us pay money for these plastic dividers
didn't even work all right now our kids
have to stay home on zoom no thanks
irish democracy jessica ditto
no no
i'd rather talk about irish goodbyes
actually
irish democracy so something that's
interesting about poll questions like
this is that they're really broad right
so would you you want less government in
your life yes or no but if you go to the
individual issues there are a lot of
places where americans the overwhelming
majorities actually do want government
in their lives like you have polls from
the kaiser family foundation that even
show a majority of republicans want a
public option for instance they want
expansion of medicare you have
majorities of americans that are four
vaccine mandates you have people who are
pro-masking et cetera so you have to be
careful about just saying this means you
know joe biden has had a terrible you
know six months in office and they're
turning against the idea of big
government it's the individual policies
that count regulation has always been a
place where people want the red tape cut
but they do want the government the
federal government to help with climate
change for instance but when you ask the
follow-up question
who is paying for it or should people
lose their job
for forced vaccination the answer is no
yeah well even though thousands have
lost their jobs that's all there is to
the question we're on to you pollsters
justin
all right meanwhile
what camera should i say this that one i
only have five words the fastest is up
next hi i'm brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now